good morning well listen I mean if you
forget if you're a migrant Landing in
this country if you're a martian like in
this country you wouldn't believe we've
had a Tory government for the last 12
years look I I see every day as the
mayor of London the the benefits of
migration to our city and our country
the issue is uh you've got to make sure
there is a safe way for those who have
fleeing persecution Asylum Seekers and
refugees to come here otherwise uh they
are driven into the hands of criminal
gangsters and they pay at literally
thousands of pounds and risk their lives
to uh come here so what the government's
got to do is have a humane way for
people to come here lawfully
in a way that they can process their
claims but at the same time have proper
Collegiate working with not just France
countries in the EU countries in North
Africa and it's really important to
realize that you need to do both have a
Humane immigration policy but also to
make sure you control the borders yeah
but what about those economic migrants
who are coming just because they want
custody alive in the UK well listen uh
last year we had 40 000 up until
November trying to come across the
English Channel 40
000 so clearly the actions of brother
and Patel here's the point many of those
who were coming maybe fleeing
persecution or Asylum Seekers there is
no other way right if you're fleeing
persecution to make a claim to uh the UK
so if there was a proper system set up
you could make sure people could apply
in a safe way but also you could make
sure by working closely with with France
by the way president macron has been in
position for some time we've had a
conservative prime minister for 12 years
there's no reason why this dog deal
couldn't be done uh you know over the
last six years since we left the
European Union the same goes by the way
with other countries in the EU the same
goes with those countries in North
Africa of course we've got to be dealing
that source with the issue of people uh
you know leaving the coast in a
dangerous uh dinghy but it's combination
of a safe way for people to have their
claims processed but also clearly
working with those at source what did
you make of the immigration Minister
Robert generic used to be the housing
minister of course uh housing secretary
who who said that people were coming
here for one of the reasons is that the
hotels are quite nice that they get to
stay in well I've not been to some
hotels that Robert generic has been to
what I do know is having seen and heard
some of the stories from those at
manston I think nobody would you know
try and come here to stay at Madison but
we can't escape the fact that if you're
fleeing for your life if you're an
asylum Seeker if you're a refugee in
amongst you there may be people who are
coming here for other reasons economic
migrants to improve their quality of
lives and so forth but we conflate
Asylum Seekers refugees students family
reunion those on work visas economic
migrants that's why it's really
important to be careful and understand
the differences between these different
forms of migration you're worried about
londoners and those that are renting and
how much it's costing them I'm really
concerned we have 2.6 million londoners
who live in private rented accommodation
they face a number of challenges that
all of us face cost to live in energy
Bills going up the government
potentially increases tax in taxes this
Thursday in the Autumn Budget on top of
that renters in London pay on average 2
500 pounds per month in the last year
alone rents have increased by the
greatest amount since records began by
more than 16 and we're publishing some
research today which shows that four out
of ten of those renting four out of ten
are worried over the next six months
they won't be able to pay their rent
which could mean they've been made
homeless so we're lobbying the
government in London just like labor
colleagues and others Lobby the Scottish
government to freeze rents for this
short period of time just to allow those
families to stay in their homes during
this cost of living crisis what about
those people who you know not
necessarily fact have who are owning
these properties and are renting them
out to try to make ends meet themselves
so 40 40 more than 40 of those landlords
who rent out the properties own them
outright there's no mortgage at all and
for those that do have a mortgage what
we're saying to the government is for a
short period of time you can be
supporting these families because the
choice is at the cost of you know the
choice of staying in your home uh
because you're you've had your rent
Frozen or landlord making a bit less uh
profit and by the way there's a
president for this our government to
give them credit as a consequence of our
lobbying during the pandemic uh did uh
pause all evictions uh for those tenants
live in their homes but also have a
mortgage holiday to those people who
needed a mortgage or a holiday so it's
possible to both support these families
who are struggling to make ends uh meet
and also those small minority of
landlords who may uh you know have
difficulty squaring the circle because
of the mortgage payments uh and the rent
not going up to to do so here but here's
a problem rents go up by 16 as they have
over the last year is foreign excess of
interest rates uh or cost of living
that's why it's so important to support
these families
um I've got a friend who's recently
joined the Police Service met
um and it seems every other day she's
been called out to a stabbing what are
you going to do about her well firstly
thank you your friend for joining the
police service we are recruiting in in
London uh we now have more than 34 000
officers which is the most we've had in
recent times because of our investment
from City Hall and without being in any
way complacent about the issue of uh
stabbings and knife crab we have a buck
the national Trend in London so in
London unlike the rest of the country
we've seen knife crime going down knife
crime with injury going not enough gun
crime of course not enough I'm not
complacent so both as a member of
Parliament and as uh mayor I meet brief
families I also meet victims of crime
one homicide is one too many in this
year alone uh the first 11 months we've
managed to reduce by almost 70 the
amount of teenage on the size because of
being tough on crime supporting the
police but also tough on the complex
causes of crime supporting young people
Youth Work youth workers giving them
after school clubs clubs at the weekends
uh clearly not enough I'm particularly
concerned about register you know knife
crime but violence against women and
girls so we're supporting women's groups
but also tackling perpetrators as well
How concerned are you about potentially
um Mr Corbin trying to take your job off
you well listen I've got I've got the
best job in the world I'm surprised I'm
not surprised uh that the newspapers are
reporting uh that other people want the
job listen uh one of the reasons I
wanted to be the mayor was to give back
to this city that's given so much to me
and my family I won't be surprised if
other people also expressed an interest
true or not in relation to being a mayor
and that's fine that's the joys of a
democracy right people can put their
names forward and run for the best uh
jobs and I'm looking forward to the
election which will be in May
2024 and I'm I'll be asking londoners to
lend me their trust in their vote again
um what do you make of the suggestions
that um and apparently we have checked
it out and it is the case that um those
in the higher echelons of the labor
party uh do not want him to be able to
stand there's a labor MP ever again I
certainly don't know about that no but
I'm asking well look I mean you know in
my view uh one of the things that care
has done really well kirst armor is to
address serious concerns around
anti-semitism I I think that one of the
reasons why my understanding is Jeremy
corbyn was had the whip removed was he's
failure to accept the report and failure
to apologize uh you know clearly if
Jeremy corbyn does apologize I suspect
the wood will be uh restored the lower
part is you know a big tent but there's
no place in our tent for anybody who
gives the impression of condonian
cemetism do you think he isn't Auntie
semi no I don't it's not I work with
Jeremy over many many uh years uh he's
not just not a racist he's an
anti-racist but you can't escape the
feelings of Jewish people who feel that
some of the things that went on when
Jeremy corbyn was a leader did condone
anti-Semitism and there were examples I
experienced it of anti-semitic remarks
made by layer party members uh they most
of them if not all of them have been
kicked out they should be kicked out we
aren't just a party that isn't
anti-semitic we should be actively
anti-racist driving out anti-semism from
from our party and from society and I
think it's really important that we show
that moral leadership but also that
sense of solidarity and there should be
no space for that in our party it's
always great
for joining us on the program thank you